all right everybody there have been so
many teasers for the title of Avengers 4
we've heard Avengers endgame Avengers
eternal Avengers eternity war infinite
Avengers Avengers annihilation and now
it appears that we have a possible new
title for it a few days ago Mark Ruffalo
went on Twitter and teased that he
leaked the title on Jimmy Fallon show
the Jimmy Fallon show then aired in
which he apparently leaked the title to
the audience and Jimmy Fallon but they
bleeped the words out when he said the
title and they put a black bar over his
mouth so you couldn't read his lips to
see what he said but one fan recorded
the audio and was able to make out what
exactly he said just a heads up my
giveaway still continues if you would
like a chance to win a copy of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray or ant-man and
the wasp a special edition poster and
some special memorabilia as well all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so the leading title right now
for Avengers 4 is Avengers annihilation
this leak came from somebody who was
apparently working inside with Marvel
Studios and when Mark Ruffalo went on
the air with Jimmy Fallon he said he
could say the title because it's already
out there this aired coincidentally the
same day that the Avengers annihilation
title was leaked but if you listen to
the audio from the fan that stripped it
down he doesn't actually say Avengers
annihilation as you just heard he says
the last Avenger
so everybody is now claiming that the
last Avenger is the new title but this
might not be so and probably isn't so
for starters the fan could simply be
trolling us there isn't really a way to
prove that the audio he has is legit but
there is a chance that it is and there's
a chance that Mark Ruffalo could have
really said the last Avenger but he
could also be trolling us if a vengers
annihilation is the true title and was
accidentally leaked they would want to
take our minds off of it and convince us
that it's not actually the title right
now I'm saying Avengers denial
is more likely the title than the last
Avenger the title comes from a very
reliable source and seems to fit the
most with what the Russo brothers said
the title would be so even though it
does sound like Mark Ruffalo said the
last Avenger I still think the best
possible chance that we have for a real
title is Avengers annihilation but let
me know all of your thoughts on this in
the comments below do you think that the
title is Avengers annihilation or the
last Avenger or do you think it's
something else let me know and don't
forget to subscribe like and comment
down below so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date with everything
related to Avengers 4 thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]